>>E'VE BEEREINE HESITANCY IS
NIYOOFLEEVER REFINE SHOT BUT A
LIS RES WHAT IA TORRT BAFOR
JUOI JOB.AU
SOCIAL MEDIA T
WE
D
>> IT S EXTREMY DIFFICULT TOTC
YON FACEBO O
WALMART THAT YOU'RA LIAR.
>> SUNNY A VUD FLOOR L AT THE H
E PANDEMIC
BEING      AS HART WA
SURREAL IS LIVING   WHEREY PEOPE
VUD IS OVERBLOJU FLU.
>> NURSES WEWHOLE
ANF TH
HAVING PEOPLE COME IN AND LOOK
US IN THE  A, NO, HE AND
S HAD LOWEST
JUST OF THE POPULATION
Y PLACES WITH LOINATION RATEOW
SEEING A SPIKE IN CASES.OU ARE H
VACCIN>> I HAVE NOT AND I WI NO.
I'M A GU.E IS NO CH.  VUD?
>> I D.
THAT'S THE RN I'M NOAFTER I GOT
>> I DON'T WANT TO. NOGET THE
TH>> YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE TA FREU
I VE MAXIM OF
ONE  IE ENTI
COVID-HIY AM I STILLING? WE HADO
LED SO THAT THEY
WOULD DIE AND REPORT IT AS
D-19.
WE HEARDRE THAN ONCE T
WE FUDGING THE N
KILLING PEOE ONTOLIKE IT WAS WR
TO MAKE IT LHEN IT
WA FIRSTITY OF
PANDEM WORE>> TELL ME WHAT YOU
>>?
>> SO, THEY DUBBED UALCA
PUBLIC
ISY WRONPRESSION,
THAT WE WERE LAMBS.
AND -- AND WILLING TO DIE FOR
YOU KNOW, I O SAVEI WANT PEOPLET
AT THE
LIC G,
WELL, YOED UP FOR THIS.
I DI'T 17, I
I KNEW THAT GH
COUNTRY.
O DIE EVEVEN WITH THE VACCINE,
THING, FOR N GOOD REASON.
>> LAST YEAR, SUNNY STARTED
GET YOU TO LISTEN TOING TOEA.
>>COVID FOR A LONG
MURDERER, SAYING I HELPED ST AE
KILL THOSE PEOPLE.GECA
.
IT'S MY INESPOND  WITH
$10 INTO MY VENMO ACCOUNT, I
>> REALLY?YOU THE TRUTH ABOUT N.
>> YH. AND PEOPLE LIKE SEND
AND YOU ARE LIKE I'M NOT A ISISI
SOME RELIEF FROM A DARKER
, HAZEL  LIKE THAT HER O TH
GOT COVILAOR FOR 42 DAYS.
>> IREAL..
I NEARLYD PROBAB, HAVE ISSUEOM .
BUT THEY'RE NONCNENG THE.
THEY UNDERSOME PE D IT'S BAD.
BUT I GOT IT AND IT S NOW, WE'
VARIANT  .
>> Reporter: SNYTHATCEAVE
BEEN TELLING HERIT AT
ISD ITS
BIGGEST SPIKE IN C SUAAS THERAH
FREE-LOTTERY TIC.T INNY.
DIW T CON S VI HOW O?
>> 8>>.
WOSO TS RARE FOR
LIKE A YOUNG KID.
>> HE WOULD SLEEP T.K.LIKE
SO GETIMD AT ANDEE
DAMAG
I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE
REAL SICK.
, FOR WEEKS.
O.. RE YOU GUYS GOING TOET
DON'T TRUST NT. NG TO GET THE
VACCINE?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
MY KIDARG  IT.
NONE OF US.
>> HOW COME?
>> I MEAN, I FIG LET W
Y.ARE YOU ABLE TO GE
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION  S
IS THAT HOW?
NO I MEAN, AKF
IF YOU HAVE TO.
SYOU
Y T
VACCINES?
>> WE DIDN'TO THE PIE
THIN W WAS.
WE DIDN'T DO ANY OF TH
I DON'T BELIIN SEEMS IT ONLYOMEN
LIKE IT'S EITHER C CONTROL
OR WHATEVER YOU WANT IT
BUT I WANT TO HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH I HAVE ALWAY
#.OT EVERYONARLSWAY.
>> I THINKOU
BECAUSE Y HELPING
YOU.
IT CAN HELP YOUR WHOLEAM.
THE SIDE THAN IT IS TO TAKE A
CHANCE ON THE COVID.
COWBOYO GET A SHOT, AND
COME OUT OF THERE LIKE A
GRP, KNOW?
WITH COMPASSIOIGGEST WITH KE TH
CAWENOS.Y THATGOOUT BECAUSE A L
CSNACNA I AL GOING TO TREAT
TH T OF MYLI
T I W MESES WHO
HAD TO QUIT BEE THEY J
DON'T VE THEM TO DO
THAT.
F THEIO HELPLD GIVE
KNOW?UT FOR A STER
K THAT A LOTOPLE
BE AND
ST PRODUCT
OFAY THAT WE WERE RAISED
RE.'RD PEOP. AND ELLE RE
THAT WAS SEAATYO
IN FOLKS.E
ME, HEARING THAT MOM, WHOS
8-YE-OD , SHSA
WEEKS.D STILL.
AND TH'RA CT
HEOUINTHAT'S -
- IFE ARTO NOT GETTED.
NOT SURWH
RYH
ALKED ABOUTI W FALL, PUBC-
EXS LDS THAT SSKEPTICISM ABOUT
IND DE AWAY, WHETE
GE
THT,R WE DID THEH ALKET WASNTHEE
SAND HER SISTER SAITH
COMING HOMS THE CHRIS
OUAYED FOR.T SHE, ALSO,D THATIV